So
I am 27 years old, and I have never had sex. Um, I
also don't drink. I don't smoke. I don't do drugs. And I don't drink coffee.
I'm
Mormon. Yay! [Laughter] umm.
And you know it's hard being Mormon in New York City and not drinking and smoking and whatever, but it's especially
hard to try to live in New York and not have sex because, you know, it's like Sex in the city and
you know, I'm young and I want to have relationships and be able to experience those things. And instead, uh,
after 6 years of living in the city
and not having sex, the longest relationship I was able to sustain was
4 weeks. And that's only because he was out of town for 2 of
them. [Laughter] um.
And you know, in addition to that, like there's this huge part of me that would love to be considered sexy
but you know if you're not selling sex you really shouldn't advertise. So instead I,
you know, I like to present myself as cute, uh - or, as someone in the audience pointed out,
like I'm on Star Trek. [Laughter]
Thank you!
So kind! Um. So you know I've gotten good at thinking of
myself
as being cute and I remember one time I was walking through the East Village and I pass this vintage
boutique and I, I walked in and there was all this vintage lingerie,
and I happened upon this slip. And it was literally the
sexiest thing I'd ever seen. It was like it was hanging on like an invisible Lauren Bacall. It
was like dark navy blue with this blue lace at the top and these
thin
straps. And I couldn't help myself. I tried it on. And I
remember I looked in the mirror at myself and for the first time in my life I was
like... I'm sexy!
Who knew that I could be sexy? and uh - woo hoo!
So I bought it.
And you know, it's not like any guy's allowed to see me in it. Because even when you're Mormon, once you get married you have to wear the garment.
So it sits in a drawer in the back of my closet. But occasionally,
late at night, I'll take it out and try it on and look in the mirror and be
like, 'I'm still sexy!'
and put it back in the drawer. Um, you know, I think there's a lot of misperceptions that
people have
about Mormons and more than anything, the one that bothers me is this idea that Mormons
say 'No.' You know no sex, no drugs, no alcohol. Which I think would make me seem like a
very boring person. But whereas I say no to certain
things. I try to say yes to everything else. Which makes me very pleasant! Uh,
And
I learned the power of saying 'Yes!' when I was going to college at N.Y.U. They used to have these
career fairs that they would set up for the business students. And I was a drama major so
like they didn't even set up booths for us. They sort of saw what was coming:
Unemployment. Um, but if you were a Stern Business student there would be all these
companies trying to recruit you. So one day I was passing through this um, recruitment hall and a
man stopped me and he was like, 'uh Are you a Stern Business
student?' And so I said, 'Yes.' He said, 'Are you interested
in a job at Morgan Stanley?'
'Yes!' And I just kept answering 'yes' to all of his questions and before I knew it I had
a free triangle highlighter with the three different colors.  And I was Like, this
is amazing! And so I just started doing that
all the time I would say 'yes!' and I ended up
stumbling into a paper convention. And next thing I knew I was, I went to a
bridal convention and I kept getting all these free trinkets just by saying,'Yes!' And it all led up
to the mother of all conventions. I had some friends in town, and we went to the
Marriott in Times Square and we were having breakfast, and my friend happened to glance under the table and there was
a badge and it said, 'Bob Barnet 7-11 Convention'. And I was like,
yes!  So we
go downstairs in this huge banquet celebrating 75 years of 7-11 so I
start mingling with people and I end up meeting the woman who organized the whole convention.
So she starts asking me for my feedback and I'm like, 'I go to conventions all the
time and this is the
best convention I've ever been to. And she's like well, you know, 'Are you going on
today's activities?' and I was like, 'Oh, Yes!' she gave me 4 tickets to
Madame Tussaud's, 4 tickets to Radio City Music Hall, and then she said, 'Will I
be seeing you on tonight's
cruise?'
"Yes."
And then she didn't give me tickets so I was like, 'Oh! But you know I sent all the stuff in and I never
got anything. And she was like, 'What?!'
She ran off and then came back with 4 tickets worth $150
each on a dinner cruise around Manhattan. So that night, me and
my friends got dressed up, and we go on this cruise and literally there's like 500
7-11 employees, and
us. So I started making friends and like I
didn't lie, like when people ask me what I did for 7-11 I was like, 'Come on man!
Leave work at work, you know?!
We're here to have fun!'
And they serve us this
4 course dinner, and at the end of it, you know, we're eating our dessert and
my friend leans in and he's like, 'Elna, I dare you to make a toast.'
And, like I don't drink so I've never made a toast, but I've seen movies. So
I was like, 'Ye-hes!' So I take my glass and, 'dink, dink
dink' and everybody shut up.
'I would like to make a toast to 7-11
For redefining
convenience!'
And they're like, "Yeah!" And what I love about
saying, 'Yes' is like, it's like where you start at
the beginning of the day and where you end up can be 2 totally different places
just based on all the things that you say 'yes' to.
And yet then there's this whole other side of my life where I do say no and, um, sex
being the biggest obstacle of them. And um, you know I think it's one thing to say no
to sex when you've been in a two week relationship, but it's an entirely different experience when you
feel like you're in
love. And, um, I met my 'Yes' counterpart 4 years ago.
I was working at a T.V. show he was in the audience and we started talking and it
was immediately, I was like,
'It's you!' And he was like, 'It's you!' And we were like, 'Yes!'. And our
first date was amazing we were, uh, walking down the streets of New York and we happened upon a movie
set and he was, like, 'We should sneak in and pretend like we're extras!' And I was, like,
'Yes!' and so we're in
the back of all these scenes and we ended up in the makeup trailer and the woman was like, 'Did the
director send you here?' and we're like,
'Yes!' and, uh,  she said, 'What did he send you here for?' and at the same time we
both said, "Black eyes."
And she gave us these huge black eyes and then we just spent the rest of the day running
around New York City with giant black eyes. And it was
incredible! And literally every date, one after the other, was like, even more exciting.
And really there was only one problem:
He didn't know that I was Mormon.
Probably 'cuz I didn't tell him. And you know
I totally rationalized it. I was like, you know, in addition to being Mormon I am many other things.
But I really, like, I wanted to be able to date him, and I wanted
to be more than 2 or 4 weeks, and so I didn't tell him and, you know,
then like, 2 months went by. And then you start to feel guilty because you start to
feel like the person doesn't really know you, because they only know half of you.
And so I told him, you know, as casually as you can say that, but I was
like, 'Oh you know, by the way, I'm Mormon.' And he's like,
'What?  Elna, I'm an atheist.
Can you be with an atheist?'
'Yes...?
And can you be with a Mormon?' and, he looked at me and he was
like, 'Yes.'
And so we kept dating. And we kept going on our adventures.
And it was great except that there were these grander things that we were
that would not leave us alone no matter how hard we tried. And I remember one of them
in particular was when I found out that he didn't believe people had souls.
I was like, 'What?!' Like, I really didn't kno-, I thought irregardless of religion everyone believed that.
But he was like, 'No, I don't believe in souls.' and I was like 'Well, then wha-...what's inside of you?'
He's like, 'Well, my, you know, D.N.A.' and I was like ,  I remember I stopped him on the
side rack and I put my hands on his shoulders. And I just looked into his
eyes, and he's like, 'What are you doing?' and I'm like, I'm
am looking at your soul and, and I--I can see it. And
I can hear it and I know that it's there! and so he said, you know,
'What does my soul have to say?' And so I listen, and I was like
'It says:  Fuck
You!'
I've been living inside you for 29 years and you've been ignoring me
the entire time!' [laughter] And he was like
it's not like Mormons are supposed to swear but then like when making a religious point was that the
only word
that came into my
head. um. And so we kept dating even though
like at this point, I realized my soul mate doesn't actually believe in souls.
But like I was willing to be OK with that.
But then, you know, the whole sex thing comes up and he's like, you know, 'Are we going
to have sex?' and I was like, "Y?? It isn't--No. no.'
And, um, so then he started to pull away, and he started
to retreat, and it's so interesting because, like, every girl knows when I guy is starting
to phase her out.  It's like even if coincidentally he didn't answer his phone that day, it's
like you know, because you feel it.
And so I knew that he was fazing me out and I started thinking well,
Why? Well it's probably because I'm Mormon, and it's probably because I won't have sex.
Then I really started to think about those things, you know, not as like, not as the way
things are as necessity but as, like truth. Like, you know, what if this person is the love of
my life, and I end up marrying some Mormon guy, because I'm supposed to. That, I like OK and I
regret the decision for the rest of my life.
Or, you know, what if he's right, and God doesn't exist? And then I end up making this
sacrifice for an entirely imaginary reason.
And then also you know, like, sex, when you feel like you could love someone
it just feels like the natural progression of things, not that it's this awful thing.
And so then I was like, well you
know, 'M--m--maybe I
could have s-sex?.. H-- no. um. No.'
And then, um, we went out again.
And we, um, we met up and, right when I saw him I could tell it was going to look, going to be one
of the last times that we saw each other. And we went to this outdoor exhibit
but it started to rain. So we ended up back at my apartment. We put on a D.V.D. we made
grilled cheese sandwiches. It was like the middle of the afternoon on a Tuesday.
And we were watching the movie, but I was still wet from the rain so I stood up and went into my
room to change. And I took off my tee-shirt and I was just going to put another shirt on
when I opened my drawer and I saw that blue slip. And
I was like, 'What if you put that on?' I was like,
you can't put that on, it's like the middle of the afternoon on a Tuesday and that would be so weird.
But then also it's like, 'But you own that, and
you've never worn it'...you know? and, also,
like what is this thing this ...sex thing? and like, you can say 'Yes!' to that,
and what I like
about saying, 'Yes' is that when you say 'Yes' everything can change. And sometimes
you want things to change. And so I took that slip out.
And I put it on. And I walked out into the living room. And he was like,
'What are you doing?' And I was like, "Shhh!" and I walked up to him and
we started kissing, and then we lay down on the couch, and we were
kissing and, the moment started to
build more than it had before and, as this was happening I leaned
into his ear and I heard myself say, 'You need to pray and find
out if God
exists.' And he was like
'What?!' and I was like "What?" uh, and
I was 'Nothing, nothing! I didn't say anything!' And so then
we started to kiss again. And the moment started to build again.
And then it happened again. I leaned is in his ear and I said, 'How can you
know that God doesn't exist unless he's at least asked?' And he was
like, 'What are you saying?' and I was like, 'I ...like, I don't know I just want to
have sex right now and instead I have God Tourette's
Syndrome!'
And so he sat up, and I sat up
and he was like, 'Elna, what are you trying to ask me?' And I was like well, "Look
the only thing...the
only reason I believe the things that I do is because I prayed and asked. And how can you know
for sure that something isn't true unless you at least
ask?' And so he said, 'Do you want me to pray?'
'Yes.'
And so he said, 'OK. I can do that.' and I was like, 'Really?'
And he you know, left and the minute he left my apartment I remember I knelt down.
And I prayed like I've never prayed in my life. When you say,
'God, you can never--you never have to answer another one of my prayers, but, answer this one.
And if he prays tell him you're there.
And then of course I made the mistake of telling my sister about this, and then she told my
parents and my parents told my uncle and aunt and my gran and next thing you know there's like a Mormon
family tree across America praying that if he prays he'll get an answer.
And
then I didn't hear from him for for 2 weeks, and then when I did we agreed to meet up
in Union Square. And we met up
and we sat on a bench together and at first it was just small talk and so finally I just asked
the question I most wanted to
ask. I said, 'Did you pray?' And he said, 'Yes.'
And I was like, 'You did? What happened?'
And he said that he sat in his room in silence. And that he prayed and he asked God if
God existed, and that he listened for a long time.
And then he realized that if he did get an answer it would just be
himself telling himself that he got an answer because he wanted to be with me, and that it wouldn't
be real.
And that was it. And the relationship ended. And you know it's, it's funny
because you know as hard as he tried to
find God, for me, and as hard as I tried to have sex for him,
we ultimately were these things that we were: a Mormon and
an Atheist.
And yet, you know, before that I always thought that I didn't have sex because I was Mormon.
But I realize I don't have sex because I don't want to have it yet, And that,
for me, sometimes saying 'No' is actually saying 'Yes.'
Thank
you.